[Applaudissements]
nous méritons nos rencontres elles sont
accordées à notre destinée cette phrase
prend tout son sens
quand je relis les dix dernières années
où comment quelques rencontres anodines
ont pu changer le cours d'une vie
je vais vous livrer un secret
le destin prend rendez-vous avec les
personnes que nous croisons mais
attention il est discret du coup il faut
y être attentif
soyons attentifs soyons attentifs à ce
sans domicile fixe qui vous tend la main
et qui vous demande une petite pièce
soyons attentifs à cette vieille femme
dont les courses sont trop lourdes
soyons attentifs à notre voisin qu'on a
pas vu depuis trois mois
soyons attentifs parce que rappelez-vous
dans les contes qui ont bercé notre
enfance la petite vieille toute Rabou
gris qui finalement se transforment en
fait et qui va devenir celle qui va
aider le héros
ce serait quand même con de la louper
pour mon boulot j'ai rencontré plusieurs
PDG des boîtes du CAC 40 j'ai rencontré
les trois derniers présidents de la
République j'ai rencontré même le pape à
plusieurs reprises
ces rencontres certes elles étaient
extraordinaires mais ce ne sont pas
celles qui ont changé le cours de ma vie
je m'appelle Loïc luisetto j'ai 38 ans
et je suis le directeur de l'association
Lazare qui anime et développe des
colocations solidaires entre des jeunes
actifs et des personnes qui ont connu la
galère de la rue
vous avez remarqué je suis pas vraiment
Mère Teresa
même si j'étais destiné à porter la robe
celle d'avocat d'affaires je l'ai porté
pendant plusieurs années le temps que
j'ai exercé ce métier mais les
rencontres dont je suis venu vous parler
ce soir en ont décidé autrement elles
m'ont permis de connaître mes faiblesses
de connaître mes peurs de les dépasser
pour oser vivre l'aventure de ma vie
la première rencontre c'est Henri un
garçon poli handicapé
celle qui allait devenir ma femme Béa me
dit alors qu'on était étudiant tiens on
va partir en week-end avec une asso avec
des jeunes
handicapés en fauteuil roulant
j'accepte
j'accepte pas vraiment pour la bonne
raison la bonne raison ça aurait été que
j'avais un sens du service qui
était très développé et que je voulais
rendre service
en allant participer à ce week-end la
vraie raison c'est plutôt qu'elle me
plaisait et que j'avais envie de lui
plaire
et que il fallait qu'elle voit que j'en
sois capable ça avait l'air de lui tenir
à coeur alors j'y suis allé j'y suis
allé en me disant bon finalement c'est
que 24 heures ça va bien se passer la
seule chose que j'aimerais ne pas faire
c'est la toilette la toilette des
personnes avec qui nous partions
on part tout va bien
4 heures après le hic il faudrait que tu
ailles changer en riz
pardon oui voilà ça couche est pleine il
faut que tu ailles le changer
tout en moi protester
je me retrouve dans la chambre avec
Henri
je m'y prends comme un manche j'en fous
partout je veux pas de dessin
comble de l'ironie en riz riz à gorge
déployée ça avait pas marché il pouvait
pas parler et pourtant il se foutait de
ma gueule
j'étais au bout
de ma barrière et j'y suis allé parce
qu'en fait j'avais pas le choix il
fallait j'allais pas laisser Henri comme
ça alors parfois on est gauche
incompétent
mais le fait d'y aller pas forcément
pour la bonne raison
nous fait découvrir qui nous sommes
vraiment alors vous allez me dire mais à
quoi ça sert d'avoir fait ça quand après
tu es devenu avocat ou dirigeant d'une
association qui passe son temps à Corée
les rendez-vous parisiens pour lever des
fonds
après
une
un colocataire Jean-Claude qui a connu
la rue la prison
déclare un cancer du poumon on était
très proche il est hospitalisé et puis
vers la fin de sa vie dit en fait
j'aimerais être hospitalisé à domicile
alors il revient à la maison et quelques
jours après cette hospitalisation à
domicile quand je rentre dans sa chambre
c'est la cata il est dans son sang il
est dans ses excréments
et je propose à Jean-Claude de le laver
j'appelle les pompiers et je propose à
Jean-Claude de laver je voulais pas
qu'ils les pompiers le voient dans cet
état
il prend sa douche et puis quand je le
rassois sur son lit il me prend la main
et il me dit ah merci mon petit Loïc
c'est le c'est le dernier moment
d'amitié que j'ai vécu avec Jean-Claude
et ce soir j'aimerais remercier Henri
puisque au moment où je donnais la
douche à Jean-Claude mais revenu à
l'esprit le fait que mon premier mentor
pour accepter qu'elle était ma faiblesse
ça avait été Henri
ma deuxième rencontre avec la fragilité
je la dois aussi à ma femme
ça aurait été mieux que ça soit elle ce
soir surtout vu mon entrée
bien me dit allez on part vivre un
projet humanitaire alors moi j'étais
dans mon cabinet de droit des affaires à
la défense
une carrière toute tracée j'étais sûr
ouais ouais on y va
après la peur de je suis pas compétent
arrivé la peur du qu'en dira-t-on ou la
peur de ce n'est pas raisonnable c'est
vrai on avait un petit bébé
est-ce que j'allais retrouver du boulot
après est-ce que c'était bien de couper
ma carrière qui se lançait bref je me
mettais à nouveau des barrières et puis
j'ai rencontré un avocat qui avait vécu
la même chose qui était parti en
humanitaire et la phrase qu'il m'a dit
c'est que
si quand je reviens de cette expérience
quelqu'un ne veut pas m'embaucher
justement à cause de l'expérience alors
c'est sûr que je n'aurais aucune envie
de travailler avec lui
c'est le déclic on part direction
Salvador de Bahia on va vivre dans une
favela un bidonville pendant deux ans
en arrivant
le choc la misère matérielle qu'on
imaginait pas la misère sociale et drame
humain
la drogue les règlements de compte
la police militaire au choc
et pourtant au milieu de tout ça une
joie incommensurable un altruisme qui
nous a dépassé
des rencontres que nous avons vécu
là-bas je pourrais vous en parler
pendant des heures j'en ai sélectionné
une c'est donna Rita donna Rita je vais
lui apporter un paquet de riz
quand je lui donne ce paquet de riz la
première chose qu'elle fait elle le
partage en deux pour donner la moitié à
Donna Barbara la voisine
mais je lui dis mais Rita qu'est-ce que
tu fous garde le riz tu as 10 enfants tu
vis dans 20 mètres carrés dans une
cabane tu as pas d'autre t'as pas
d'électricité je t'apporte du riz tu es
sympa mais tu le gardes et tu le bouffes
et là il me dit non mais Loïc
quand je quand donna Barbara la voisine
n'a rien elle me donne la moitié de ce
rien
je dois partager ce rythme
alors qu'en quelques années plus tard
arrivera pour moi le choix de quitter ma
carrière d'avocat
pour devenir
dirigeant associatif
et bien remontera la remontera dans ma
mémoire le souvenir de la confiance de
la générosité de Donna Barbara de Donard
Rita et de mes amis qui vivaient dans la
favela et c'est eux une nouvelle fois
qui m'ont permis de faire ce choix en
confiance
deux ans au Brésil retour en France
on aurait pu avoir une vie tranquille
mais ma femme a une autre idée et si
nous installions en famille dans une
maison de l'association Lazare
qu'est-ce que c'est une colocation
solidaire entre des jeunes actifs et des
personnes de la rue
ouais avec nos enfants oui c'est une
super idée non
ouais allons-y
on s'y installe et là aussi des
rencontres transformantes
la première que je vous livre Andy Andy
27 ans il a connu beaucoup la prison
un petit peu la rue
il n'a qu'un rêve percé dans le rap
Andy après quelques mois à la maison
retrouvent un boulot quelques mois après
ils retrouvent un appart et puis il
vient me voir pour me dire qu'il va
partir et il me dit tu sais Loïc
plus tard j'aimerais être comme toi
je comprends
évidemment non non pas comme toi comme
toi j'aimerais être père de famille
en fait dans la vie on passe notre temps
à faire des choses
mais la principale chose que les gens
vont retenir de vous c'est pas ce que
vous faites c'est ce que vous êtes
si vous devenez ce que vous devez être
alors c'est sûr vous allez mettre le feu
au monde entier et vous manquerez au
monde
c'est Andy
Andy qui m'a remis à ma place ce que
j'avais fait pour lui il s'en fouter ce
qui était important pour lui qui avait
été adopté très tardivement c'était ce
que je représentais
j'ai croisé Henri il y a pas longtemps
Andy il y a pas longtemps
Andy il a deux enfants aujourd'hui vous
pouvez pas imaginer la fierté qu'il y
avait dans son regard
dernier histoire
martial
martial à 37 ans il a connu la rue
pendant 20 ans
après trois semaines chez nous il pète
un plomb le mec pète tout dans sa piaule
je rentre dans la chambre et là c'est un
peu la cata quoi
et Martial
[Musique]
martial s'énerve il me dit en fait je
suis une merde
en fait ma vie n'a aucun sens
au bout de trois heures de discussion je
trouve rien de mieux que conclure en
lisant en fait j'ai réfléchi je pense
que tu es pas une merde mais que tu es
plutôt une merveille je pense que ta vie
en fait elle a du prix
la discussion se termine et puis je suis
persuadé une chose c'est qu'il va
retourner à la rue pour plus avoir à se
poser la question qui tue celle de son
avenir
et puis il reste et Martial souffre
d'addiction et suite à une mauvaise
injection il chope la gangrène
il est placé dans le coma pendant un peu
plus d'un mois
et quand je vais lui rendre visite à
l'hôpital
après son réveil il a un sourire sur qui
va durer à l'autre je dis bah ça fait
plaisir de te voir comme ça qu'est-ce
qui se passe
et en fait les infirmières m'ont dit que
depuis un mois vous vous relayez à mon
chevet tous les colocataires de la
maison
et si vous avez fait ça c'est que vous
m'aimez
et si vous m'aimez que je suis aimable
et si je suis aimable et ben c'est que
ma vie elle avait du elle a du prix
martial avait tout compris c'est au
travers de l'amour des autres
au travers de l'amour des autres que
toute sa vie prenait du sens
alors vous voyez
les leçons
que j'ai reçu au cours de cette dix
dernières années c'est pas les grandes
ce monde qui me les ont donné
c'est ceux qui sont laissés à la croiser
des chemins ceux qui sont laissés au
bord du chemin
alors se développe super bien on a 12
maisons en France on est présent à
plusieurs capitales européennes on est
au Mexique on nous demande d'ouvrir des
maisons aux États-Unis au Canada à
Londres à Prague à Rome bref il y a un
développement fort du projet de
colocation solidaire
mais ça ce n'est rien à côté
de ce que vivent ces jeunes qui
s'engagent en allant vivre à côté des
personnes de la rue pour apprendre
eux-mêmes quelles sont leurs fragilité
quelles sont leurs limites ainsi
apprendre à mieux se connaître et à
devenir eux-mêmes
alors quand vous croiserez ce SDF qui
vous tendra la main quand nous
croiserons cette vieille dame qui a du
mal à porter ses courses quand nous nous
dirons tiens ça fait trois mois que j'ai
pas vu mon voisin est-ce qu'il va bien
peut-être que ça vaut le coup d'aller
voir rappelez-vous
le destin il peut se cacher
derrière ces personnes et ces personnes
peuvent venir la fée qui viendra
transformer votre vie
alors oui si vous allez voir ces
personnes en galère si vous allez voir
ces personnes délaissées elle est
peut-être dans votre entourage même
cette personne délaissée si vous prenez
le temps de la rencontre peut-être que
vous allez illuminer leur journée
peut-être que vous allez illuminer leur
journée
mais peut-être surtout que ça va
révolutionner votre vie et alors c'est
sûr c'est une certitude vous connaîtrez
la joie
merci
[Applaudissements]